i would like to bring you to the world
of alexandria ocasio-cortez
in this tweet
from ursula pirano she says aoc on talks
about her future ambitions with a heavy
comment quote realistically i can't even
tell you if i'm going to be alive in
september and that weighs very heavily
on me all right hold on hold on a girl
did some mushrooms huh
life doesn't even exist it's okay to cry
now hold on there's several questions
does she have a terminal disease
right it's called life yes is she
suicidal that's a serious question
because saying something like that i
think people haven't thought about what
she could mean by this suicide right and
if she's not sick and she says something
like i don't know if i'll be alive
usually that's a sign of depression
especially in the context of this
article she says a woman of color can
never be present because people hate
them or something it's like very
negative she was crying when she said
this really
she they said that she had tears in her
eyes
yeah
maybe she needs like a 50 150 or
something she needs to be brought
somewhere and give it an evaluation
because if you tell people crying that
you don't know if you're going to be
alive in september we need to sit you
down and ask you what's wrong because if
you ignore this something bad could
happen we want her to be okay
and i know the left is going to be like
oh shut up i'm not like no dude
you you okay we're going to play a game
pick one do you think she's referring to
a civil war and that racists would come
and kill her by september yes you think
that's what she's talking about i think
she's shook up from the january sixth
thing and it hasn't left you think that
a couple weeks ago she was sitting there
thinking a couple weeks from now a bunch
of white racists are gonna start a civil
war and i'm gonna die she probably
thinks that she's a target if something
like that were to happen she'd be like
after january 6 she was like i i could
have died but she's not walking around
see this this is my point right the
assumption a lot of people make is that
she must be talking about like what
kathy griffin is talking about something
like that the other question is okay all
right most people are probably going to
think it's something to do with
political conflict we still have to ask
questions about like dude i'm the civil
war guy i'm like ranting and raving
about it and i don't think in three
weeks there's gonna be a bunch of
racists going around hunting down women
of color maybe it's climate change
her comments were more of like uh mark
ruffalo didn't he have this thing he's
like if we're around for the yeah
she did say the world was going to end
in 12 years a few years ago right
is she been living
it wouldn't matter if she's alive or
dead like when you're living your
purpose you don't lament about when it
might end you're just doing it so
obviously maybe she's lost a lack of
purpose she feels kind of aimless this
was a crazy interview on a lot of
friends i also enjoyed doing it that she
said she wasn't sure it would be like
good for her to marry a white guy she's
currently engaged to a white guy that
she's been doing maybe she's like yeah
she's gonna kill me in my sleep
she's got a lot of anxiety she needs to
work out and i'm i'm being a little
sarcastic there but also like you are
setting yourselves up for a lot of
scenarios where you feel like at any
point your life could fall apart and or
be in danger like something is wrong i
think she might be suicidal really maybe
i think i think we we are looking
through the lens of the culture war
and so we are assuming that someone
political like aoc must be referring to
what we see instead of asking a very
simple question when you hear hooves
it's not zebras it's usually horses the
gq article says
tears pooled in the corners of her eyes
she says i hold two contrary things in
my mind one is the relentless belief
that doesn't anything is possible at the
same time my experience here is giving
me a front row seat how deeply and
unconsciously as well as consciously so
many of these people in this country
hate women and they hate women of color
people ask me questions about the future
and realistically i can't even tell if
i'm going to be alive in september why
is the immediate assumption
like if if you if you started off
from a blanket
no reference to any individual
and said someone says that in three
weeks they might not be alive your
immediate reaction will not be well
they're talking about civil war no yeah
you'd say wellness check yeah you'd be
like okay why do you think that the
first question might be like are are
they sick like someone who thinks
they're gonna die in a few weeks are
they terminally ill they have cancer i
mean maybe aoc does and we don't know
about it i don't know but i think
i i i either sh look either she's insane
and she thinks that a bunch of crazy
extremists are going to come kill her
which
that sounds insane
or she's depressed and crying in an
interview about how people hate women of
color and she doesn't know she'll be
alive in september right but yeah her
leading with the people hate women of
color is the thing that's kind of
bringing me into the fact that maybe
she's talking about extremism or but
also if you grew up always believing
that you were the victim and your job is
to overcome you've got to do it and like
you're also the victim but you're still
kind of winning because you got to
congress but also you're still the
victim either way
exactly that's her when she opens like i
hold two contradictory things on my mind
like this is a very divided person yeah
if if she said this to like a
psychotherapist who wasn't involved in
the political world he'd probably be
like um you need about a three-month
vacation girl well well three days an
evaluation hawaii or something and
look at the waves just sit on the beach
if she genuinely believes
that there's going to be white racist
men hunting women of color that and
that's why she'll die she needs serious
therapy she needs a break right now i
don't know how long but she needs to get
out and she needs to go talk to a doctor
because that's crazy
she's
i think it's i think it's a fair
assessment to say she lives in a world
where biden comes out and says the maga
extremists are a threat to this country
where she hears the news all day about
white supremacists and she genuinely
internalizes and believes this is the
world she lives in that's possible too
but i also think that is still using our
echo
chamber world view
we know about political problems so to a
hammer everything looks like a nail we
assume that political people must view
the world this way and if she does
that's the real reason when in reality
it's like dude she's extremely high
profile she gets people [ __ ] on her
all the time
maybe she's just like maybe not the
person is
i can have a lot of empathy for that uh
you know i will point out again i know
it sounds random but she did get engaged
in april and i think that you the idea
that she's moving forward with this
high-profile relationship she's already
in congress like where do i go from this
pinnacle career i mean people regularly
include her in polls to become president
like what if she is actually unhappy
with where her life is she can't walk
away from this right that was a big big
change
like people rag on her i think it was
great that she was a bartender i think
that the idea that a regular person can
you know get a seat in congress is
fantastic i think it's stupid to insult
her over it but imagine going from no
public persona to being the one of the
highest profile democrats yo it is
stressful one of the highest ranking
officers on the death star the united
states the military machine is the death
star and all these people working in
congress are serving on the death star
so i understand her state of mind is
broken because she's like what am i
doing what like that's just existential
that's like underneath the the content
on top of what she's been feeling and
this girl's tuned in emotionally she's
like we're talking about leftists are
emotional rightists are logical where
she's very emotionally informed with
what she's feeling like with mark
ruffalo he was asked will you be the the
hulk in the future and he goes if the
world allows it and i'm still around the
interviewer didn't follow up with hold
on there a minute do you think you're
gonna die
the interviewer here as well should like
well you're not gonna be alive in
september
a good interview is going to be like are
you sick yeah are you depressed or do
you think the war is going to break out
in a couple weeks especially if she's
been on the verge of tears throughout
this whole interview like it's well i
don't know about the whole interview it
said that's that point right if you're
hitting emotional notes in an interview
and then this sudden person said i'm
like and i'm gonna i might not even be
alive in september like you're not
having a like ha ha we're joking around
i don't even know if i'll be alive that
like you have to respond to the gravitas
of what's going on this is like i got a
clarifying question only hitting with
serious notes
i've got to say that
breaking moment right now i went through
that in 2008 and i was suicidal i
thought for sure like i gave up i
thought oh the world like we've got the
federal reserve has we've been under
this system like there's no ho i had
completely given up but i i still wanted
to have hope i had that other part of my
brain like she's saying where i'm like i
know everything's possible here's what i
want y'all to do right now and just stop
second imagine someone sitting in front
of you
think of a random person you know crying
says to you i might not be alive in a
few weeks well why why that was the
first thing i was saying but exactly the
fact that she said this it's like again
we're approaching this from a political
perspective yeah think about how you
would feel if someone you knew told you
that yeah so it'd be like yo we need a
doctor like yeah you're like
okay for the next three weeks i'm the
doctor right now i'm not a doctor by the
way but tell me why at least you know
let's start with friendship and then if
it's unresolvable maybe we'll get a
psychotherapist this is this is a crazy
thing to say and they probably crazy
thing to not follow up on especially
like where's the journalist in this one
wesley lowry what are you doing okay so
journalists aren't mandatory reporters
like you have in the hospital in the
hospital if somebody said something like
this yes you are on suicide watch you
don't get to have any cords you don't
have any cutlery you have to eat finger
foods let's clarify that if in the
hospital someone told you i might not be
alive in a few weeks
you would report them and we would put
them on suicide watch which was
supposedly what epstein was on he
clearly wasn't because he still had
access to sheets you don't have access
to anything right when you get arrested
they take your shoelaces and your belt
exactly and and because they don't want
you to kill yourself or someone else i
would imagine i've had several family
members baker acted and as soon as you
say anything toward the lines of of
harming yourself it's immediate you're
being put in a facility and you're there
until they feel like you're not a threat
to yourself anymore but you know you
know what's going to happen she's making
this comment to a journalist like what
is she saying to people she really
trusts and knows like that's what's
disturbing to me i think what you're
going to hear is many on the left are
going to dismiss this down play it say
it's the far right because they would
prefer she be in a desperate and
dangerous position if it wins their wins
for them politically that's right they
don't care about her oh the sad part if
she did go and do something to herself
the amount of people who would like use
it as a story and use it as a way to
move forward their political agenda
another possibility is she is a
sociopathic narcissist who faked tears
and said this to try and win brownie
points in the media not think like
believing to herself there's no real
threat and she's just a crazy person
well and if she is someone whose
emotional spectrum is kind of off she
can perform motion she knows how to cry
you know on cue let's say
but she doesn't actually always feel the
weight of her words you know she can say
like i might not even be alive and not
know what what the appropriate response
for that to be like if she pictured
someone's in front of her saying i might
not be alive in september would she
respond with like
we need to talk about that are you okay
or would you respond with like well i
really need you to vote i know early
then i know what's going on what's going
on tell us tim aoc
is likely depressed because of instagram
and tick tock thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there